- I'm anti-vaccine.
- Anti-vaccine.
(intense music)
- I am not vaccinated and
I haven't been vaccinated
and I have two kids, they
haven't been vaccinated either
and that's all vaccines.
- The whole COVID
plandemic kinda woke me up.
- It feels like discrimination
when I tell people I'm anti-vax,
or I haven't been vaccinated.
- I'm a pharmacist and when they put in
with the COVID vaccination
I just felt really uncomfortable.
It's just made me open my eyes
to how many things are in vaccines,
and how much we don't discuss
them in the medical community.
- My anti is toward COVID vaccines.
Actually, truth be told,
the rapid test we just took
was the first COVID test I've ever taken.
I refused to take a COVID
test, the vaccine was pushed
so that they could rig the election
and that's personally my belief.
- [Interviewer] So you believe
the election was rigged?
- I believe it was, yes.
- Cool.
- Growing up I got
most of my vaccines, however,
I especially did not want
to get the COVID vaccine.
The media censorship was
the biggest star to me,
kind of like he said, waking up to this.
- We know ourselves better
than going in to a doctor
who only sees us for a
few minutes at a time.
- You said you were a pharmacist?
- Yeah.
- Did you leave your work,
you kinda implied that?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
With the increase of the vaccine mandate,
and having it required
for the rest of the chain,
so I actually have a family
member that does work-from-home
from an independent mail-order pharmacy
and she got me a gig there
and since then they've been pretty chill.
- So you left willingly, they didn't like
ask you to leave?
- Yeah.
- So I used to, actually,
I started as a teacher
in elementary school
and they actually asked me to leave
because it was mandated that
you had to be vaccinated
to be in a group of kids.
So that was really frustrating for me
because working with kids
is a big passion of mine
and the fact that I was
fired for my career,
just because of a personal choice,
is really upsetting to me.
- Yeah.
- So that's why I'm very
passionate about this issue now.
- I was actually asked
to leave nursing school.
I started for a month
and then they accepted
my religious exemption
and then a month into it
said, "Nevermind," so.
- Yeah, I lucked out 'cause
I go to college in Oregon
and at first they were like,
"No, you can't come in here
without a vaccine," and everything,
but I was able to get the
philosophical exemption
and then they wanted to test me weekly
and I was like, "No, I'm not doing that,"
and then after kinda going back and forth
they were like, "Okay, you're fine."
(all talking at once)
(laughing)
(bell ringing)
(upbeat rock music)
(clicking)
- I wrote Brian because
in the waiting room
we were joking that his
name was Brian, not Ryan,
and then I...
- That's okay.
- Okay.
(clicking)
- He was able to get a
philosophical exemption
which I had never heard of.
(clicking)
- There's no way
you could get away with
not having a COVID test.
- Most people have gone
through at least one by now,
we've been two years in.
(buzzing)
(exhaling)
- I could not believe that
I got voted out first round.
If anybody is the mole, it's
not me, that's for sure.
- How has not being vaccinated
affected your guys'
personal relationships,
like friends and family?
- I had to miss a wedding
that I was really excited for
for one of my friends back in Indiana.
She ultimately decided to
ask everyone to be vaccinated
because her grandparents were there,
which I completely understood,
but it was really heartbreaking
to not be a part of that
special day with her.
- Yeah.
- One side of my family refused to see me
so that was kind of disheartening
and I feel like people tie
certain political views
to my personal idea not to get vaccinated.
I'm not a right-wing extremist,
which I feel like a lot of
people are associating me with.
I am not just someone
who is not vaccinated
I actually have natural immunity.
I have contacted the virus before
and multiple studies have
shown that natural immunity
actually lasts longer,
as far as resilience to
contacting COVID again.
The right to our own body
is the opposite of tyranny
that would normally be
associated with that.
- Yeah, I'm very
Libertarian-leaning.
- Heck, yeah.
(fire exploding)
(upbeat rock music)
(bird screeching)
- My ideas aren't
I line up with a Republican or Democrat,
for me it's just-
- Yes.
- We should have the ability
to decide what we wanna do.
- Yeah, and I just think
it's scary too when the
government starts to say
they're doing this for your own health
and your safety and-
- Yeah.
- It's just funny how all of a sudden
the government started
caring about your health,
wouldn't they have banned
smoking cigarettes,
years ago.
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- It just seemed like a lot of censorship
to not be able to find
any other information
about side effects.
I have a few friends who
had some bad side effects,
but you can't,
once you post that out there
it's censored.
- Censored, yeah.
- Even the VAERS Report
there's thousands of reports-
- Yes.
- Of people with vaccine side effects
and people pretend like
that's not a reality.
- And I think it's interesting how they
care about our health and everything,
but they say nothing about nutrition,
sunlight.
- Yes.
- Working out, going to the gym,
getting outside and being
around people that love you,
and stuff like that,
that's good for your health.
- Right.
- Instead they lock us in, in a room
with artificial lighting-
(light buzzing)
And paint, and don't get sunlight,
and don't get to talk to people, yeah,
and then they put a mask on us
which is not healthy at all.
- Nico was throwing
out a lot of buzzwords.
He kept saying, plandemic,
and I think he said jab,
it very much so looked like
he was making a character
and he was really trying
to hit all the the buttons.
I was teaching first grade
and a lot of those kids,
because of the COVID lockdowns,
they had never had any social experience
for the past two years
and to act like that is detrimental
to their social health,
to their mental health,
it very frustrating.
- Where do you teach, what?
- San Bernardino County.
- Okay.
- I was saying, I personally don't think
that it's really
anybody's business if I've
been vaccinated or not.
- Yeah.
- And I don't think that
I should not be able to go
certain places, eat certain places,
or even enroll my kids in school
because they haven't been
vaccinated, it's just not,
it's not fair and it's
really nobody's business,
my health, you know.
- You said none of your,
your kids don't have
any vaccines, right?
- Nope, I have never had...
- How did that affect
them getting into school?
- Well, they're three
and two months.
- Oh, okay.
- So she's, they're not old enough yet,
but, yeah, I haven't
been vaccinated either
and it it hasn't affected me in any way.
When I get sick, I get sick
for like one or two days
and then I'm done.
- Yeah.
- I'm back healthy and I only get sick
maybe like two times a year.
- You said that you
moved down to California?
- Yeah, yesterday.
- But, I'm trying to get out.
- Yesterday?
(laughing)
- I'm trying to get
out of California-
- Yeah, no, me too, yeah.
- So why did you move to California,
it's so hard to go for-
- For sure, yeah.
So, lived in Texas for 10 years,
then I moved to Oregon for school ,
and then I got a job
offer as an internship
here in California.
And honestly, yeah,
all the mandates and
everything I don't like,
but I mean, it's California,
it's kinda like that kinda,
the dream to come
and live here, so.
- I'm gonna try
to switch with you,
I wanna go to Texas.
- Yeah, for sure.
(laughing) Yeah.
- I'll take your old spot...
- I'll be back soon.
(bell ringing)
- I'll take your old spot.
- Yeah.
(light upbeat music)
(clicking)
- He went to university
in Oregon and somehow wasn't required
to get vaccinated there.
- Why would someone move
from a more conservative
area to a liberal area
if they were anti-vax?
(clicking)
(buzzing)
- [Girl] Sorry.
- [Guy] (indistinct) After.
- [Interviewer] If you think the mole
is still in the box, and you'd like
to continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
- Can I ask who everybody voted for
in the elections (chuckling)?
- I voted for, oh, you're talking about
the actual election?
- Yes.
- Oh, I voted for Trump,
again, like I'm Libertarian,
that isn't really my,
I'm not a Republican,
but he definitely was a better choice
over what we have now.
- What about everybody else?
- Yeah, I'm Libertarian
as well-
(bird screeching)
And I actually believed that
neither of the candidates were good
and I did not feel comfortable
supporting either of them,
so I did not vote.
- Right, I didn't vote either,
I haven't voted in two years.
- I haven't voted either.
I felt really uncomfortable
with just how nasty
everything was getting,
everything kept getting
more increasingly cloudy,
I felt like, as the election
came closer and closer,
so I just didn't feel like
I had enough information
regarding either of them to
confidently cast a ballot.
- I get that, I mean,
they're both really divisive,
but the effects matter,
and seeing, especially
what's going on now,
I mean, we might not like
either of the candidates,
one of them is gettin' in
and we gotta do our best
to get the least of two evils,
I think that is important.
- I mean, I personally voted for Trump.
I actually worked on his campaign
because I actually do, I
don't like everything he says,
but I like his policies and I believe
that he allows people to live their lives
and doesn't try to get involved
with all of your business.
- Wait, so you said you worked
on his campaign?
- Yes.
- Did you, you guys didn't
have to get vaccinated
for that, or?
- So that was the
2016 campaign.
- That was 2016, okay.
- I don't think he would have
required it for the 2021,
but I worked at the 2016 one.
- Okay.
- Didn't do anything for the 2020.
- Asabi, I wanted to ask
you more about your stance
because we mentioned earlier
that in general you don't feel
like it's anyone's business.
We kinda touched on autonomy,
I wanted to hear more about
why you, specifically,
decided not to vaccinate
yourself and your children?
- So I grew up very, religious
I guess you could say,
and my belief, like vaccines are a no-go.
We don't believe that
we should put poison in our bodies,
and we think that we should
just handle everything
in holistic ways, so.
- She was like religion,
religious reasons, is she
thinking about this on the spot?
- And I Corinthians 2:5 says,
"Our faith shouldn't be
trusted in the wisdom of men,
but in the power of God."
- Exactly.
- And so for me
that doesn't mean that
man has ultimate wisdom,
but what they try to push up,
this is what you need to do,
that automatically
throws red flags for me.
- He used a Bible verse for
me, that was like, okay,
he believes in kinda like
the same thing I believe in.
Biblically speaking, for me it's like you,
back when, in Pharaohs, in those days,
they were killing babies and
then with the vaccine it's
I just don't trust it because-
- Yeah.
- You're trying to mandate something
that could possibly harm or kill someone
and that's (indistinct).
- As a pharmacist
I know how much Big Pharma puts money
in this constantly.
- And their line for so long
has been, oh, we're against
big pharma-
- I was gonna say that.
- And then all of a sudden they jump in
and it's like everyone needs
to listen to what Pfizer says,
everyone needs to listen to what
Moderna and J&J says.
(bell ringing)
(clicking)
- She said that she was
very much into the
pharmaceutical industry.
(clicking)
- She kind of said she
wasn't very political
and I feel like at this point
it is kind of a political statement
if you are not vaccinated.
(clicking)
(buzzing)
- [Interviewer] If you feel like the mole
is still in the box,
and you'd like to
continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
You need a majority vote
and since it's just the two of you
instead we're gonna ask, can
you share your suspicions,
let's air it out and
let's have a conversation.
- I know it was Nico,
that's number one (chuckling)
- Yeah.
- Just because I think he
was throwing out buzzwords,
like he developed the character.
- And he also talked about how he didn't
have to get the vaccine
at first in Oregon.
- Go to college in Oregon.
- I was pretty confident it was Nico,
I don't know who the
other person would be.
I don't suspect anyone else.
- I think it was Ryan too, honestly,
'cause Ryan, when he first said,
"This is the first COVID
test I've ever taken.
I trust you, I do trust you,
but you do seem very much like you've
researched a lot.
- Neither of you guys
voted in the election
you said, correct?
- Right.
- I do find that kind of interesting
just because I feel
like it is so polarized.
- I'm totally with you on that mentality,
but just being around a lot
of Libertarian circles-
(bird screeching)
There are a lot of people,
and you guys both kinda said
you're Libertarian, right?
- I really, I honestly don't really have
a strong political view, honestly.
- Where we are now in the world
it almost is a statement
to not be vaccinated.
Now, it's not just like,
oh, I wasn't provided enough information,
I wasn't, you can go to
CVS and get it for free
so you are kind of making
a political statement,
whether you like it or not,
if you aren't vaccinated.
- I assume most of us don't agree
with the mainstream media,
or watch a lot of that,
because obviously there's a
narrative that's pushed there,
so I was gonna ask what
type of media outlets
do you guys consume?
- I follow
"The Daily Wire," Matt Walsh,
Ben Shapiro.
(indistinct).
Candace Owens, those are probably
the people I listen to the most.
- "The Daily Wire" I've had
a little bit of trouble with
'cause Ben Shapiro has really
promoted vaccines.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I-
- I do like Candace...
- I disagree with
that part, yeah.
- I like Candace Owens,
but yeah, I don't know,
I've kinda gone on and off of Ben Shapiro,
but I like Steven Crowder.
I like Dr. Robert Malone, Hank Pecker,
there's a lot of different
streamers and media outlets
that I think do push a more
like you should be able
to choose what you want
for your own body.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
(clicking)
- She worked in the medical field
and that is an area where you do
have to typically be vaccinated.
(clicking)
- I think being anti-vax
is a big political statement
so that looked a little off to me.
(clicking)
(buzzing)
(footsteps)
- I was pretty bummed.
I thought I had spoken
pretty well about my beliefs
so I was surprised.
- [Interviewer] If the lights turn red
that means a mole is still
in the box, and you lose.
If the lights turn green that means
you have voted the mole out, and you win.
(high intensity techno music)
- Maddie's a mole.
- No, it's not me,
it's you!
- It's you!
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- It's gotta be you.
- I think it's Maddie.
- [Interviewer] So on the count of three
I'm gonna ask the two moles to step out
and reveal themselves.
One, two, three.
- Oh!
(exclaiming)
(hands smacking)
(background talking)
- I shoulda known it Mason.
- Going into it
I was like, okay, he and I are alike,
we have an alliance, we're good.
He definitely sold me, so,
well done my friend.
- I'm very politically engaged
so I've had a lot of
conversations with people
just about whether or not
people should get vaccines,
whether or not there should
be government mandates,
that type of thing.
I've heard a lot of
opinions on both sides.
My goal here was to kinda
just be really subtle about it
and kinda just sew doubt in the vaccine,
not really take a hard
stance of, plandemic,
or microchips, you
know, that extreme wing,
'cause I don't think anyone really here
is on that spectrum.
- Honestly, I said that
'cause I was trying
to get some points 'cause I thought,
if I say plandemic, (clicking
tongue) I'm good to go.
- Yeah, I'm a pharmacist.
I actually was a part of the
initial movement to vaccinate.
I went to nursing homes,
put vaccine in arms.
A big part of my experience with that
is just seeing how much of a toll
COVID has taken on my
fellow healthcare workers.
I have people that work in the ED
and see how tragic that is.
One of my closest friends
actually lost your father to COVID.
There's a lot of data in medicine
that I question all the time.
As a person of color, and as a woman,
I know how much the data is against
people like me being treated,
but the vaccine is
something that I've seen
time and time again that I
don't typically question,
the data just stands for
me, so I stand with it.
I really do understand why a lot of people
are concerned with how
far can government reach
and what does that mean
for the common people?
Where do we draw the line?
I think that is, genuinely,
is a super important conversation to have.
- Most people who are
skeptical, of the vaccine,
are either consuming that
from certain media outlets,
or just people that are around them
really pushing that idea.
If we, as people who think
vaccines are important,
don't actually interact with them
they're just kinda stuck in that bubble
and that's not helpful for anybody.
(energetic music)
(background talking)
- [Mason] High fives
around, high fives around.
(cheering)
(clapping)
Oh yeah, I love this.
(cheering)
I'm always ready.